madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour
inquiétudes très vive en italie après
l'attentât de bologne un attentat qui a
fait 76 morts et 203 blessé et qui a été
revendiqué à deux reprises par un
mouvement fasciste d'extrême droite
les jeux olympiques de moscou se termine
dans ce journal nous essaierons de
savoir comment les américains ont réagi
à ces compétitions auquel ne
participaient pas leurs athlètes menaces
contre la citizen band ces postes de
radio amateur qui connaissent un très
grand succès depuis un an serait
totalement interdit à l'automne prochain
eric tabarly a mis pied à terre ce matin
à 9h30 dans le port de la trinité près
de quiberon accueillis au large par des
dizaines et des dizaines de voiliers de
vedette éric tabarly et ses coéquipiers
ont reçu un accueil particulièrement
chaleureux europe numéro 1 qui avait
organisé la tentative réussie de records
du monde de traversée de l'atlantique à
la voile a pu recueillir les premières
impressions d'eric tabarly qui comme
d'habitude s'est montré modeste face à
l'accueil enthousiaste qu'on lui
réservait et au compliment dont on le
couvrait ces images ont été prises hier
et c'est à ce moment là eric tabarly
passer au large de la bretagne ce soir
dans notre édition de 20h nous verrons
évidemment le reportage de cette arrivée
triomphale dans le petit port vous savez
que tf1 c'est assure en exclusivité le
film de ce record du monde réalisé en un
peu plus de 10 jours contre 12 jours et
quelques heures pour le précédent record
vieux de 75 ans l'un des équipiers
d'éric tabarly dominique pippa est aussi
un virtuose de la caméra c'est ce film
exclusif de ce record du monde que je
vous propose de découvrir un film
commenté par maurice olivari
le 17 mai 1905 la goélette atlantic
quitte le port de new york à bord 40
hommes d'équipage
à leur tête le meilleur skipper de
l'époque charlie barr
les trois hommes ont décidé de relever
le défi vieux de 75 ans l'un d'entre eux
s'est même payé le luxe d'embarquer à
bord douze bouteilles de saint-émilion
pas une de plus à 18h ce 21 juillet eric
tabarly
eric bourhis et georges calvet kit
manhattan avait que deux mini pippa
caméraman
premier rendez-vous le feu d'ambrose au
large de l'ong island
c'est là que fut donné en 1905 le départ
de la course
en pleine nuit les gardes-côtes
américains enregistrent leur de départ
il est 21 heures 43 minutes et 10
secondes
mardi 22 juillet le vent est bon le
voilier fils à 12 noeuds
maurice est à la barre tabarly et calvet
se reposant leur couchette
soudas l'amarrage de tête de mât du spi
casse net
la grande voile bleu jaune et rouge
s'effondre et vient s'accrocher au
peloton
tabarly et calvet réveillé en sursaut
n'ont pas le temps de s'habiller
qu'on tente d'abord de sauver la voile
mais très vite le spi se déchirent
et tabarly décide de l'abandonner c'est
le coup dur la catastrophe qui survient
après 12 heures de course
il ne reste plus à bord que veut spi
eric choisi de jouer la prudence
il faudra pour l'instant se contenter du
grand chênois
ainsi toile et le trimaran vient de
perdre au moins en eux à l'heure le
calcul est vite fait anneux x 24 heures
x 10 jours égale 240000 égal au mieux
une journée perdue
ça ne pouvait pas plus mal commencer
malgré tout en 24 heures le trimaran a
déjà parcouru 275000 pour l'instant
charlie barr et eric tabarly son bord à
bord
mercredi beau temps au show des poissons
volants
eric a conduit son bateau sur le gulf
stream il a choisi dit qu'il de prendre
le tram un pain qui doit lui faire
économiser 1/2 nos valeurs
vingt-quatre heures de méridien
améridiens son bateau vient de couvrir
285 milles alors tabarly décide
d'envoyer le spi de brise
adieu prudence il y à un record à battre
il faut savoir prendre des risques
mais au cours de cette manoeuvre l'un
des équipiers a commis une faute grave
de celles qui peuvent provoquer des
catastrophes
eric se fâche coup de gueule justifier
ce sera la première et la dernière fois
jeudi jour anniversaire d'eric tabarly
on lui prépare son plat favori entière
bodmer deux tiers d'eau douce 500 g de
pâtes aux oeufs une goutte d'huile dans
l'eau pour éviter qu'elles ne collent
des oignons que l'on fait blondir dans
le beurre du corned beef il la sauce
tomate
le tout à servir tiède pour ne pas
brûler le palais et pouvoir déguster la
troisième bouteille de saint-émilion du
voyage
le trimaran vient de pénétrer dans le
royaume des pêcheurs de morue au large
de terre-neuve avec la brume impossible
de faire le poids mais tabarly continue
de donner le cas il est chez lui et
donnait ses équipiers l'impression de
pouvoir naviguer les yeux fermés depuis
le départ le trimaran a parcouru 920000
plus de 15 100 km charlie barr et la
cantine sont déjà lâché
samedi votant le retour du soleil permet
à nouveau de car le poids petit drame
domestique
dominique pippa fatigué jette à l'eau
toutes les pochettes du bord en faisant
la vaisselle
eric est condamné jusqu'au bout du
voyage à manger ses spaghettis à la
cuillère
dimanche vitesse 13 15 le la lure ne
cesse d'augmenter
le vent forcit 18 puis 20 noeuds à la
barre on s'équipe masque sur les yeux et
ris ou les paquets le maire anton son
air favori vogue la galère
ces vitesses le bruit que fait le
trimaran dassier est un par balle
côté confort c'est pas mieux imaginez
une citerne vide dans laquelle sont
installés des sièges de bois tiré par
une locomotive à 150 à leur non pas sur
des rails mais sur des pavés l'image
signée georges calmettes
ces traitements durent quarante huit
heures dominée pippa inscrit sur son
livre de bord je crois cette fois eu le
record est battu
mardi le vent faiblit au fil tout de
même à 10 noeuds eric annonce qu'il ne
reste plus que six ans 74 milles à
couvrir
une sorte de grand face même
depuis new york et en sept jours
l'équipage a parcouru 4300 kilomètres
charlie barr est loin derrière
mercredi gros temps à nous 17 18 19 me
regardez bien le deuxième cadre ans à
partir de la droite le voici l'aiguillé
bloqué à 20 noeuds
les fonds sont énormes
l'avant du trimaran se précipite dans
vide
calvet et tabarly qui s'activent à la
proue sont balayées par la mer eric
s'écrase contre la poutre des flotteurs
eric se relève en se tenant l'épaule il
a mal très mal au point de la boue à ses
équipiers mais la blessure n'aura pas de
conséquence sur le déroulement de
l'épreuve à bord sans jamais oser se le
dire chacun sait que le record est battu
jeudi le vent mollit le soleil revenu et
le bréguet atlantique de la marine
nationale salue le trimaran les copains
déry sont venus le saluer
il reste 60 milles à parcourir il reste
encore à bord de bouteilles de
saint-émilion à déguster il est alors
possible de franchir la barrière des 10
jours mais le vent se défile on arrive
tout juste en cherchant bien à trouver
de quoi fabriquer 1 4 noeuds gains
fragiles tabarly est en panne
la cote est là mais la nuit passera sans
que le voilier réussissent à franchir la
ligne d'arrivée au petit matin même vent
même panne à coups de bord on se
rapproche de la côte ont frôlé les
rochers c'est gagné eric prend les
écouteurs europe 1 associé à
l'entreprise annonce la victoire
il n'y aura aucune manifestation de joie
de la part du skipper tout juste
quelques applaudissements de ses
équipiers
à 8h57 et 30 secondes les cartes côtes
anglais enregistre le temps de passage
du trimaran entre lui et charlie barr
eric tabarly a réussi à mettre deux
jours d'écart voilà c'est donc le
reportage exclusif tf1 que vous venez de
découvrir avec nous des images tout à
fait exceptionnelle et je vous rappelle
au cas où vous ne seriez pas un familier
de la voile que ce fameux de charlie
barr dont on vous a parlé depuis
quelques jours c'est ce commandant
américain qui à bord d'un voilier qui
s'appelait l'atlantique détenez le
premier record de traversée en un peu
plus de deux jours en 1905
nous reviendrons évidemment ce soir dans
notre édition du 20 heures sur cet
exploit et nous espérons plus accueillir
eric tabarly dans notre studio énorme
titres dans la presse italienne ce matin
après l'explosion de bologne qui a fait
76 morts et 2 103 blessés monstrueuse
attentat épouvantable tragédie un
massacre une tragédie un attentat
fascistes voilà les gros titres qui
s'étale à la une des différents
quotidiens italiens
car l'attentât ne fait plus de doute
pour les enquêteurs ils ont en effet
découvert sous les décombres dans un
angle de la salle d'attenté le cratère
provoqué par l'explosion d'une bombe
sylvia le parquet de bologne va ouvrir
une enquête pour atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état
il justifie sa décision en s'appuyant
sont une nouvelles constatations opérées
au cours de la nuit alors évidemment la
thèse de l'attentât comme on pouvait
déjà le craindre dès hier soir est plus
que vraisemblable
même si le peuple italien se refuse à la
croire
trouvant cette action revendiquée par un
groupe d'extrême droite trop monstrueuse
et pourtant cette hypothèse ne fait plus
de doute
en effet cette nuit un trou de 1 mètre
cinquante de diamètre et de 20 cm de
profondeur a été découvert dans un coin
de la salle attentes des seconde classe
et sur les murs des traces noires
permettent de conclure à la mise à feu
des explosifs contenus dans un sac en
plastique noir toute la nuit 500
sauveteurs aidés de grues et depuis le
dauzère ont continué à la lumière des
projecteurs à fouiller les décombres
des milliers de spectateurs silencieux
ont suivi leurs efforts
le nombre des victimes est déjà très
important mais il devrait encore
augmenter
certains blessés se trouve en effet dans
un état désespéré
la première hypothèse avancée hier soir
et l explosion accents dit accidentelle
d'une chaudière
elle n'est donc plus retenue par les
enquêteurs les services techniques de la
gare affirmant que toutes les
installations sont intactes plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont manifesté dans
les rues de bologne et reçoit en signe
de solidarité avec les victimes et les
syndicats italiens ont décrété pour
demain matin une grève générale de
quatre heures
vive inquiétude pour les droits de
l'homme en bolivie après le coup d'état
militaire monsieur les chin président de
la centrale ouvrière bolivienne aurait
été assassiné le 21 juillet par des
hommes de main du pouvoir des hommes des
femmes et des enfants auraient également
été massacrés par l'armée bolivienne
c'est ce qu'a déclaré une représentante
du conseil oecuménique des églises les
journalistes internationaux travaillent
dans des conditions très difficiles en
bolivie ils sont expulsés ou surveiller
et menacer notre envoyé spécial jacquet
grignon du moule loin du moulin a
néanmoins fait le point après le coup
d'état militaire dans les principales
mines d'étain de bolivie notamment akata
vie et acide ou bent et le mouvement de
grève et de résistance populaire a
presque cessé mais les militaires ont dû
négocier avec les leaders des mineurs
qui ont posé leurs conditions exigées
des garanties
on considère et lyon n'ont cependant
dans la région de roobow de potosi
normalisation qui doit permettre la
reprise de la production d'étain
principale ressource du pays n'est pas
encore intervenu maison
à la paz en revanche le calme continue
de régner à l'ombre des fusils les chefs
militaires auteurs du coup d'état du 17
juillet dernier paraissent avoir la
situation bien en main mais ils sont
préoccupés par les réactions résolument
hostile des etats-unis de l'eau et à des
paysans d'un tardivement il y a quelques
jours le nouveau président bolivien la
générale mais ça s'est avisé de
comparaître devant la presse étrangère
et nationale ou du moins le peu qu'il en
reste là pas drôle de conférence de
presse que celle du général mais ça
ânonnant péniblement le texte qu'il
lisait l'impression s'est confirmé que
les officiers généraux qui se sont
emparés du pouvoir était vraiment les
moins doués de leur génération
en somme aux yeux du général mais ça ce
sont les calomnies de la presse qui ont
fait croire qu'il y avait eu coup d'état
la présidente galère n'a pas été déposé
elle a renoncé d'elle même à ces
missions étaient à l'avenant et en tout
cas le général mais ça l'a réaffirmé les
dernières élections étaient frauduleuses
et l'armée mettra le temps qu'il faudra
pour repérer le cancer marxiste malgré
l'opposition des américains des chinois
et de fidel castro et yemmouni ford et
le produit mondial elle revient dans des
écoles après ce message toute question
était peut-être superflu brésil et 112
dommage que l'aide de camp du général
est tout simplement tranché vous allez
l'entendre
messieurs les journalistes il n'y a pas
de question
et quant à la répression question
insignifiante aux yeux des maîtres
actuels de la bolivie
elle inquiète pourtant l'église tout
entière
lu dans toutes les paroisses dimanche
dernier une lettre de l'épiscopat
condamne implicitement le coup d'état en
affirmant que les élections du 29 juin
ne paraissent pas avoir été entachée de
fraudes gras comme nous le dira en
personne monsignor manriquez
l'archevêque de la passe qui s'inquiète
d'autre part du secret concernant le
sort des détenus des disparus de ces
deux dernières semaines
la situation est angoissante
nous n'avons pu obtenir aucune
information sur l'arrestation et nous
n'avons pu effectuer aucune visite dans
les lieux de détention
les rumeurs qui circulent vous les
connaissez ce qui m'inquiète c'est la
déclaration du secrétaire de l'onu
réclamant le respect des droits de
l'homme en bolivie et la cessation des
exécutions sommaires violation de la
soummam qui peignait la masse et s'est
couché aunès
comme l'argentine la bolivie aura ses
disparus qui n'auront pas leur place
dans les cimetières de l'altiplano
en israël baisse considérable de
l'immigration ces derniers mois une
moyenne de 2000 immigrants contre 3000
l'année dernière le chef du département
de l'immigration de l'agencé juive
attribue cette baisse aux informations
démoralisante publiées par la presse
occidentale sur la situation en israël à
jérusalem ce matin on accueille avec une
gravité particulière la suspension des
négociations
décidée par le président sadate une
décision qui intervient après le vote du
parlement israélien considérant
jérusalem réunifiée et dans sa totalité
capitale d'israël
menace sur la citizen band la radio des
citoyens à ces postes émetteurs
clandestins et illégaux récepteur le
plus souvent monté sur des voitures vont
être totalement interdits d'ici à
l'automne prochain
c'était un administrateur de la
direction générale des
télécommunications qui a fait cette
révélation
il y en france entre 50000 et 100000
automobilistes qui dispose d'émetteurs
récepteurs dont la portée varie de 10 à
50 km alors il ne faut surtout pas les
confondre avec les radios amateurs qui
ont des licences parfaitement légal et
qui pourront donc continuer à émettre et
à recevoir le président valéry giscard
d'estaing a assisté hier soir en vendée
à puy du fou un spectacle d'art et
d'essai ce spectacle retrace l'épopée du
peuple vendéen du moyen-âge à nos jours
il comprenait 500 acteurs et le
président giscard d'estaing qualifié ce
spectacle de tout à fait remarquable et
de très grande qualité
les jeux olympiques de moscou se termine
nous aurons l'occasion de faire un bilan
de ces jeux d'abord cet après midi dans
l'émission du service des sports
présenté par jean-michel leulliot et
réalisé par solange peters
et puis dans notre édition de 20h ce
soir bernard giroux proposera un résumé
des plus grands moments de ces jeux
olympiques des jeux qui ont permis à la
france de remporter 14 médailles dont 6
en or et 5 en argent mais des jeux qui
resteront marquées par la politique
puisque de très grands pays sportifs
comme les etats-unis l'allemagne de
l'ouest canada et le japon ne s'y sont
pas rendus en 1984 les prochains jeux
olympiques auront lieu à los angelès aux
états unis comment les américains
ont-ils perçu et suivi ces jeux de
moscou auquel il ne participait pas de
washington dominique bromberger
ces taches rouges dans l'assistant du
kennedy center de washington ce sont les
uniformes des membres de l'équipe
olympique américaine l'uniforme qu'ils
auront servi quelques jours là l'effet
ch'ti ce n'est un peu teintée d'amertume
de la part de ceux qui auraient bien
aimé quand même faire le voyage de
beauce ont visiblement un gala de
variétés et la remise de quelques
médailles du congrès ne suffisait pas à
faire revenir
un peu plus tôt le président carter
avait accueilli blanche mais sa décision
du boys hot on avait reçu que deux
arrondissements mythe
l'atmosphère était plutôt morose chez
les membres de l'équipe olympique qui le
barbecue organisé sur la pelouse de la
maison blanche avait un air de fête
mais en fin de compte il n'y a pas eu de
protestation direct c'est que l'amertume
des athlètes est très minoritaire dans
le programme de télévision
les américains accordent dans une
couverture minimale aurait publié dans
les journaux télévisés aux jeux
olympiques mais la colombe le meur dont
wayne rooney lampard et d'officiels
soviétique où un arbre et la veille et
on brosse qui avait montré à
d'équitation la manche la double
obligation pour que les meilleures
équipes ni par classe malgré quelques
rares tee shirts ou tenant le boycott
l'atmosphère est plutôt à l'indifférence
vis-à-vis de ces jeux on eu quelques pas
de là
mais c'est une
sam à moscou perm en berne et des
équipements hors du regard des bus
certains programmes peuvent également
passer de ça ne m'intéresse pas pris
puisque nous atteler n'y sont pas ses
clés
pour moi le boycot des joies de la vie
même ne veut rien dire
non mais vous devenez face à une femme
aurait mérité de regarder sa tête il y
avait été admis soeur x the moscow à
ligne fixe
are you in terris sadate orleans m non à
noailles that pourquoi au film
intéressant
vie j'essaye même de les ignorer
while at pourquoi ça véhicule était une
sorte de taxe de patriotisme
les américains se préparent maintenant
pour los angeles en 1984 pour eux c'est
presque comme si moscou n'avait jamais
existé
je vous rappelle donc que si vous êtes
un passionné des sports les deux rendez
vous pour un résumé des jeux olympiques
de moscou 16h30 cet après midi sur tf1
avec le service des sports de
jean-michel leniaud jean michel viau qui
présentera et le journal de 20h ce soir
avec bernard giraud la météo c'est
aujourd'hui le grand beau temps de la
bretagne à la côte basque en passant par
tout le sud-ouest vue de satellites ce
matin à 11 heures grâce au centre
météorologique de lannion on peut en
effet constater que c'est le grand beau
sur la moitié ouest de la france
une grande zone nuageuse qui part de la
normandie jusqu'à la côte d'azur se
déplace sur les frontières de l'est
accompagné de quelques pluies orageuses
et à l'arrière de cette zone c'est le
retour du beau temps avec des
températures moins élevées encore
quelques bouchons ce dimanche sur la
route des derniers retours et des
derniers départs mais rien de dramatique
je vous souhaite au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 week-end un excellente
après-midi merci et rendez vous ce soir
à 20 heures